sagen wir mal so retten so dass sie sich
für einen laien die web anhört kann
jeder
ok also nein ich gehe es gibt eine
auswahl an ausnahme
mörder mörder
ich fühl dich gut wenn nein hört sich
alles ein herzlicher vieles wenn sich
jetzt ein typ da hinstellen und einfach
sagte ich will am block du lust kopf
gehört sich dass wir in leinach web an
der fensterseite können wird japan wird
trap ab wann wird es fertig man im
endeffekt jetzt 2013 ist inzwischen
alles schon rap wenn man sich nicki
minaj anhört sie auch eine rapperin was
die datei wird macht es für mich ganz
genau das gleiche wie damals
ich glaube diesen aquamit war ideal das
ungefähr genau das gleiche
damals war das kein rap jetzt website
aber ich bin sehr froh darüber muss ich
sagen also web hat sich auf jeden fall
geöffnet
du hast heutzutage sehr sehr viele stile
im rap ganz halt auch nicht zu klar
definieren aber natürlich von der wurzel
her ist es sprechgesang sozusagen man
verpackt entsprechenden menschen mit
reimen in eine breite hose aber mehr
oder weniger kunstvoll natürlich also es
ist kunst kunst kommt von können solange
einer wirklich retten kann ist es kunst
wenn ihr mann nicht retten kann ist es
blödsinn aber gut okay was mir wichtig
ist ist das echt klingt was wovon ich
das kotzen bekomme ist zum beispiel wenn
ich mir leute alle die dazu deutschland
sucht den superstar gehen und zuerst
eine wunderschöne stimme haben und dort
hinkommen der schönen natur stimme
dann kommen in welche coaches die sagen
nee mach mal so und und übertreibt das
tremolo das vibrato und danach kommen
sie zurück mit einer vollkommen
überspielten perfekten plastik stimmen
das heißt nicht nur der gesang das ist
nicht alles
die und dass jemand gelenken kann er
sogar das teil sozusagen und das hast du
dir immer bewahrt deinen style also bis
ja auch nicht zu einem major label
gegangen sondern ganz bewusst so gesagt
ich mache mein eigenes ding klar weil
ich wenig verbogen werden
ich war schon mal ein mensch also ich
war als 18-jähriger war ich in einer
gruppe waren so ein bisschen die straßen
culcha candelas daher okay ich habe
damals französischen reggae gemacht wie
gesagt war damals bei der emi gesignt
und ich habe heute einfach gesehen wie
das auch mit 50 oder 100 leuten in einer
etage nicht laufen kann wie das einfach
so ist dass sich jeder kümmert aber im
endeffekt niemand was macht und jetzt
habe ich mein eigenes label mit meinem
partner ronny boldt und meinen besten
freund hamoudi und noch einen weiteren
mitarbeiter und wir haben zusammen mit
der bng also wir haben sozusagen quasi
das eine
kooperation aber wir stehen für uns wir
machen unser ding und haben das rudel
namen sozusagen das ist ideal für mich
also man hat schon dabei sind in der
klassischen musik einfach so themen
gehört die einfach schon mal verwendet
wurden so wie man jetzt website die auch
schon mal verwendet wurden sozusagen und
das halt man kann sich nie neuer finden
aber was halt jetzt dazugekommen ist
etwas wunderschönes ist es gibt
unendlich viele sounds ja okay das ist
geile und dubstep ist zum beispiel wie
einfach sounds also wirklich ja
allerdings deshalb das problem darf hat
nur einen zaun
da hab ich an während das gerät werbe
dubstep hatten einen rückwärts vorwärts
es hat halt diesen babbel basso was du
wo man halt ich meine okay ich bin dabei
allerdings hält aber dubstep ist für
mich halt dieser doppel busters jeder
charakteristisch dann wie du die du am
set wie damals die metal bands und so
und wie gesagt macht heute alte musik
mit sounds ist nicht mehr wirklich die
melodie zählt nicht einmal die ganzen
radiohits an dass meistens meine melodie
drüber weise auf einem turm
das ist ein ton und eine beschissene da
kann ja jeder heute musik machen das
heißt weil weil es eben auf diese was
ich am anfang schon erwähnt aber es
kommt nicht darauf an wie gut du singst
wie gut an texten videos rüberbringt ob
du quasi leute sich mit ihr
identifizieren können und ob das gefühl